it's still January right yeah it is
definitely still January Hansel and
Gretel witch hunters stars Jeremy Renner
and Gemma Arterton the movie starts out
with a kind of Tim burton-esque feel
these two little kids get lost in the
woods their parents abandoned them there
they of course find the house made of
candy and there's a witch there and
stuff goes down except it goes down a
little bit differently like it does in
the classic fairy tale and eventually
these kids grow up to be witch hunters
they are honoured amongst the land as
the people who are best at killing
witches they're hired as bounty hunters
to do so and in this one particular spot
these witches have been kidnapping kids
and they don't know why and these kids
are all just disappearing and they are
called in as bounty hunters to try to
find these kids rescue them and kill all
the witches involved now this movie had
a lot of problems in production the
rating changed often there was reshoots
it got pushed back multiple times never
a good sign and now it's coming out in
January which is usually regarded as the
trash heap for movies and much
deservedly so Council and Gretel I
really did not like this movie now I can
understand how someone might go to this
film and have a lot of fun with it it's
definitely a mindless piece of
entertainment where you can just kind of
go and just you know what I don't care
about anything is happening on screen
right now I'm just going to munch this
popcorn and have eighty five mercifully
short minutes of my life be entertained
I can understand if he felt that way but
for me this movie was just filled with
way too many WTF moments to truly be
able to like this movie the script of
this movie makes absolutely zero sense
characters aren't actually characters in
this movie oh look there's Hansel and
Gretel oh they're so cool and everything
let's hire them to kill witches all you
guys are so cool like that's the entire
basis of their character that they're
just these really cool guys with guns
and stuff that definitely did not exist
in their time period the kid from
Project X is in this movie and he's
basically this guy he's like oh my god I
love you guys I hear about you all the
time he's like this fanboy for Hansel
and Gretel and I didn't really
understand his inclusion in this movie
of course near the end they kind of wrap
him up in the whole thing and I can see
why he's in there now but it's just I
didn't really like his character I
didn't really think he brought much of
anything except kind of a little bit of
annoyance to the film fomka Jensen plays
the big grand evil witch in this movie
and I'd like to say that she does a good
job
but let me give you an idea of how these
people were directed to act
each witch in this film is that
incredibly over-the-top
type thing or they're just like you will
listen to me and do as I say I am me the
sad thing is I'm actually not
exaggerating at all that's pretty much
how all the witches talk in this movie
and after a while it's like oh boy this
is definitely one of those exercises in
100% mindless action entertainment with
characters that don't matter
plot points that don't make any sense
for instance Jeremy Renner has this
thing where he has to inject himself
according to him every couple hours with
this serum or he will die except there
are long extended periods of time in the
movie where you know that he hasn't
taken any of it but he's still breathing
so I don't really understand that that's
just a little nitpick though really my
biggest problem with this film is that
it's just so stupid and it doesn't make
any sense sometimes you can tell that
the script in the direction for this
movie was just completely off and no one
really cared about anything like
characters just burst through doors fall
like three stories down and like oh
there you are I've been looking for you
I haven't seen you in a long time
where'd you go oh I don't know I was out
walking in the woods how'd you find me
I fell through the three storey thing
and here you are yay let's hug not very
good there are a few good things about
this movie the production looks very
nice there are some good action scenes
the stars don't really have chemistry
but you can tell they had a little bit
of charisma for some of the material
even though you can really see in a lot
of shots they just don't want to be
there but one thing I definitely liked
about this movie was some of the makeup
work and I really liked the use of an
actual costumed troll it wasn't like
some big CGI thing it was actually kind
of like in the olden days like the movie
the labyrinth where everyone had cool
puppetry and everything and I did like
that for sure there's a lot of practical
effects in this movie and I will give it
that that's pretty cool but for the most
part I found this movie to be a big dumb
cheesy over-the-top film and all the
worst types of ways I'm gonna give
Hansel and Gretel Adi thanks a lot for
watching guys and as always if you like
this and you can click right here and
get stuck Manoj